uh so they both can be on the floor yeah
that's
one of the advantages of having that's a
great find there great patience by
quickly who had a terrific
rookie campaign by agreeing to a
four-year contract extension which is
expected to be signed
shortly it's not official yet now we can
focus on hoops and something he's
incredibly excited about is the addition
of evan fournier and kemba walker
jackson there with that turnover and
that's one as a guard you're like come
on big though
quickly inside gets it back outside the
top and
back to quickly for three money a minute
to go
here in the first half we got a todd
ball game
quickly to the hole through the teeth of
the defense somehow
gets his default the finish through
contact
so the pacers all of a sudden to head by
six again
quickly drops duarte drops to three
then eisen so check it out again there
it is
the step back dortay he's so smooth and
under control you know he
reminds me a little bit of malcolm
brogdon too who was another guy that
came into the league
really mature and you know at 24
he's not overwhelmed what did you see
from him
that showed that development as he gets
the steal and quickly on a fast break
finishes smooth over the defense those
are guys that have been playing so well
if you're the pacers
you want to make sure they're involved
with the offense here
the outside shot is good and the knicks
have their largest lead
of the game ahead by seven
know about that ability to shoot that
three-pointer in rhythm with the step
back and he has
especially on the defensive end you see
that as bone drops to the floor
and quickly drops one from three
emmanuel
quickly so hot he could heat the sun up
31 points now
and we know quickly has that face after
making shots there it is
once again